el sistema rs se usa para describir la
configuración de un centro quiral aquí
tenemos un par de enantiómero del lado
izquierdo tenemos un compuesto y del
lado derecho tenemos su imagen especular
asignemos rosario3 com el paso 1 en el
paso 1 hay que priorizar los 4 grupos
unidos al centro gira eso lo podemos
hacer de acuerdo al número atómico
empecemos con el enantiómero de la
izquierda este carbono es el centro que
irá y tenemos cuatro átomos diferentes
unidos a este carbón por acá tenemos una
versión sintetizada de la tabla
periódica y miren de estos cuatro átomos
el bromo tiene el número atómico más
alto así que el bromo tiene la prioridad
más alta vamos a darle el número uno
después tenemos el cloro con un número
atómico de 17 así que el cloro es el
número 2 después tenemos el flúor con 1
número atómico de 9 así que será el
número 3 y finalmente el hidrógeno como
tiene el número atómico más bajo tiene
la prioridad menor el hidrógeno es el
número 4 ya está el paso 1 ahora en el
paso 2 hay que orientar los grupos para
que el grupo de menor prioridad se
encuentre hacia atrás bueno en este caso
el grupo de menor prioridad es el
hidrógeno pero miren ya se encuentra
hacia atrás porque está representado con
líneas punteadas así que el paso 2
también ya está finalmente en el paso 3
hay que determinar si la secuencia 1 2 3
es en el sentido de las manecillas del
reloj o en contrarreloj
entonces ignoremos el hidrógeno y veamos
qué pasa con el grupo 1 2 y 3
miren 1 2 y 3 están en esta dirección y
esta es la misma dirección de las
manecillas del reloj así que este es el
enantiómero r
este es el ere bromo cloro flúor o
metano ahora hagamos lo mismo para su
imagen especular sabemos que este
carbono es el centro que irá y también
sabemos que el bromo es el número uno
el cloro es el número dos el flúor es el
número tres y el hidrógeno es el número
cuatro ese es el paso 1 en el paso 2 hay
que poner el grupo de menor prioridad
lejos de nosotros pero miren ya está
lejos así que el paso 2 también ya está
finalmente en el paso 3 hay que
determinar si la secuencia 1 2 3 es en
el sentido de las manecillas del reloj o
encontrar el ojo bueno
ignoremos al grupo de menor prioridad
que se encuentra lejos de nosotros y
vamos a ver del grupo 1 al 2 y al 3 nos
movemos en esta dirección es decir
encontrar reloj así que este debe ser el
enantiómero
este es el s bromo cloro flúor o metal y
ese fue el paso 3 así es como podemos
asignar la configuración de un centro
que irá
y aquí tenemos otro par de enantiómero
del lado izquierdo tenemos un alcohol y
del lado derecho tenemos su imagen
especular empecemos con el de la
izquierda este es el centro girar y
queremos asignar su configuración pero
voy a redibujar la molécula este es el
centro quiral y unido a este carbono
tenemos un h que está representado con
una cuña también tenemos un hidrógeno
que está lejos de nosotros aunque no
está dibujado sabemos que ahí está
después del lado derecho tenemos un
grupo metilo dibujemos un ch3 y
finalmente del lado izquierdo tenemos un
grupo estilo que consiste en 11 h todos
ch 3 ok entonces este es nuestro centro
quiral pero analicemos los átomos que se
encuentran unidos directamente a este
carbono aquí tenemos un oxígeno un
hidrógeno y después tenemos 2 carbonos
asignemos la prioridad de este lado
posee una versión muy sintetizada de la
tabla periódica y miren de todos estos
átomos el oxígeno tiene el número
atómico más alto así que el oxígeno
tiene la prioridad más alta el grupo o h
es el número 1 mientras que el hidrógeno
como tiene el número atómico más bajo
tiene la prioridad más baja es el número
4 y después tenemos 2 carbonos que
tienen el mismo número atómico pero para
saber cuál tiene mayor prioridad
analicemos los átomos a los que se
encuentran unidos por ejemplo el carbono
de la derecha está unido a 3 hidrógenos
23 lo escribiré hidrógeno hidrógeno
hidrógeno y el carbono de la izquierda
está unido a un carbono un hidrógeno y
un hidrógeno escribamos esos átomos en
orden decreciente del número atómico el
carbono tiene un número atómico más alto
al de los hidrógenos así que podemos
escribir carbono hidrógeno hidrógeno
hagamos la comparación del lado
izquierdo tenemos carbono hidrógeno
hidrógeno y del lado derecho tenemos
hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno entonces
aquí tenemos carbono pero acá tenemos
hidrógeno y como el carbono tiene un
número atómico mayor este grupo tiene
una prioridad mayor
el grupo de tilo tiene mayor prioridad
que el grupo metilo así que el grupo de
tilo es el número 2 y el grupo metilo es
el número 3
ahora que ya asignamos las prioridades
vamos a reescribir las abajo e lo h es
el número uno
el grupo estilo es el número 2 el grupo
metilo es el número 3 y el hidrógeno es
el grupo de menor prioridad y se
encuentra lejos de nosotros así que
también ya tenemos el paso 2 finalmente
el paso 3 es observar la secuencia si
pasamos del grupo 1 al 2 y al 3 nos
movemos en esta dirección es decir en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj
entonces este es el enantiómero r este
es el r 2 butanol y claro si este es el
r2 butanol entonces la imagen especular
debe ser ese 2 butanol pero vamos a
corroborar este es nuestro centro quiral
y sabemos que lo h es el número 1
el grupo estilo es el número 2 el grupo
metilo es el número 3
recuerden que tenemos un hidrógeno que
está lejos de nosotros entonces como el
grupo de menor prioridad ya está lejos
de nosotros sólo tenemos que observar la
secuencia de los grupos 1 2 y 3
miren del grupo 1 al 2 y al 3 nos
movemos en esta dirección es decir
encontrar reloj por lo tanto este es el
s2 butanol
ya vimos que este es el s2 butanol pero
qué pasaría si nos dan la estructura de
la derecha y nos piden que asignemos la
configuración del centro que irá bueno
aquí tenemos el centro quiral y esta vez
como el que se encuentra lejos de
nosotros entonces el hidrógeno está
hacia nosotros y bueno ya vimos que en
orden de prioridad el o h es el número
uno el estilo es el número dos el metilo
es el número tres y el hidrógeno es el
número cuatro pero en el paso 2 nos
dicen que debemos orientar la molécula
para que el grupo de menor prioridad se
encuentren lejos de nosotros y aquí el
grupo de menor prioridad se encuentra
hacia nosotros porque está representado
con una cuña lo que podemos hacer es
tomar el hidrógeno y en nuestra cabeza
pasarlo hacia atrás
así nos quedará lo mismo que tenemos del
lado izquierdo estas son dos formas de
representar el mismo
en el vídeo sobre cómo dibujar
enantiómero hay un vídeo de la rotación
de este compuesto para demostrar que
estos dibujos representan el mismo
compuesto aquí el hidrógeno se encuentra
lejos de nosotros y así es como
obtenemos la configuración es porque
este grupo es el número uno este es el
número dos y este es el número tres y
como nos movemos en esta dirección que
es contrario al de las manecillas del
reloj la configuración es ese pero qué
hacemos si no queremos rotar la molécula
en nuestra cabeza bueno a veces es un
poco difícil aquí no fue tanto pero a
veces puede ser confuso en ese caso hay
un truco que podemos usar empecemos con
el dibujo de la derecha primero hay que
asignar la prioridad de cada grupo y
después simplemente ignoramos al
hidrógeno no importa que esté hacia
nosotros solo observen la secuencia mire
de 1 a 2
3 nos movemos en esta dirección es decir
en el sentido de las manecillas del
reloj
entonces la configuración sería r parece
er pero como el hidrógeno se encuentra
hacia nosotros en realidad la
configuración es contraria a lo que
parece
parecía r pero como el hidrógeno se
encuentra hacia nosotros en realidad es
ese este es un pequeño truco que pueden
usar en lugar de rotar la molécula
primero asignen las prioridades
determinen si es erc o s y en realidad
será lo contrario